I have to ask you something mmm we were
talking about it on the show recently
you've been very close to you I mean
you've been in the White House but
you're very close to the White House as
the son of the president do you think
there's a possibility that the United
States government is covering up the
existence of extraterrestrial life it's
so funny it's the question I wanted to
ask my father for a very long time you
think there's aliens being covered up
I've wanted to ask I'm almost too
embarrassed to ask again about like
serious like if you get one question
like it's probably the question but I'm
sort of embarrassed admitting that you
know so I don't know maybe you do it
like casually you go ours on this radio
show and it's a mess like do anything
aliens exist I mean that was a stupid
question what do we think yeah but do
you think so or no you know listen I
would find it as a as a believer in sort
of math and statistics even though that
those two are now racist today well
you've seen those right I mean you know
that is that is what some are trying to
convince is oh hey I would find it hard
to believe that in a universe the size
of ours and and whatever's beyond that
that there's not something there you
know I I don't I don't know that there's
some sort of massive cover-up I don't
know that I necessarily believe that but
I would find it hard to believe that
that's some sort of other life out there
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM f
[Music]